THEY NEED HIM TO BE BETTER.
HOME PAST
GRUBAUER.
THE AVS HAVE THE 1-0 LEAD ONCHET
GOAL OF THE GAME AND THIS LINE
IS
PAD OF FRANCOUZ FOR THE THIRD OF
THE SEASON AND THE KRACKEN W W .
COMING ACROSS TO THE  PLAY HARDL
CON
HE JUST FIRED IT TO THE FRONT OF
THE
>> DID IT HIT BY
GIORDANO.
DON'T SEE THAT VERY OFTEN.
>> TH
AVS MISPLACED THAT ONE.
DUNN WALKING RIGHT OFF J.T. DEFE
ICE, STRAIGHT DOWN AND BOUNCED
OFFF REBOUND, SCORE!
[ HORN ]
>> GRUBAUER MADE THE FIRST SAVE
BUT HE CANNOT AND FOR THE
COLORADO AVALANCHE WITH THREEE .
STRAIGHT UP FOR HORIZON.
KADRI SHOOTS.
WHAT A SAVE BY PHILIPP GRUBAUER.
BEST OFOFUSHKIN.
ROLS TO MacKINNON.
BACKHAND SIDE TO THEOWN.
DROPS IT OFF.
MacKINNON HOVERINGDEVON TOEWS CE
NEAR SIDE.
MAKAR GOT  SKATE INTO IT.
THAT WILL BE A GOOD GOAL, PETE.
IT ABSOLUTELY IS.HELF!
RIPS IT PAST GAME,
THEY ARE DOWN 3-0, 4-1.
YOU
TO EBERLE.
SHOT SAVED BY FRANCOUZ.Y
THE AVS' NETMINDER.
>> I GO BACK TO